maryvonne tous les jours maryvonne vient
faire le ménage chez eugène 98 faire les
repas les lessives la toilette des
tâches essentielles du quotidien as
qu'elle a continué à assurer même durant
la période éprouvante du confinement
je voulais me sentir utile auprès des
personnes j'avais vraiment peur
oui j'ai été soutenu responsable mais
franchement oui je suis très peur
maintenant non ça on écoute - laquelle
est enfin qui ont fait messieurs - dans
sa prochaine paye maryvonne touchera la
prime qu'ovide au même titre que des
soignants dans cette association comme
dans beaucoup d'autres on se félicite de
cette reconnaissance
un peu tardive attendent avec il y avait
une prime qui était donné pour les
soignants qu'on les applaudissent est
tous les soirs et puis que nous nous
aide à domicile elle n'avait rien eh ben
on était vraiment déçu si vous voulez
parce que nous on connaît nos aidé à
domicile on sait qu'elle se donne à fond
donc on s'est battus quoi au niveau
national tout le monde tous les acteurs
s'y sont mis il a maintenant c'est fait
mais c'était difficile
une équité rétablie et la satisfaction
pour maryvonne d'avoir assuré un rôle de
rempart face à la progression de
l'épidémie
c'est une reconnaissance déjà parce que
si on n'avait pas été là donc les
personnes qui n'avaient personne
vraiment mais pas de famille et tout
donc je pense qu'elle aurait été
hospitalisé heureusement que nous on
était présent pour s'occuper d'elle une
prime exceptionnelle dont les modalités
de versement contesté reste encore à
définir
en attendant cette association puisera
dans sa trésorerie pour la verser à ses
dix salariés